we under with all our ego we are far
behind
and so let's get talking about this
traffic situation
winters
I close my eyes in real life I've been
around the world three times in the last
six months but I still can't remember
the last time you truly get lost
in my backyard there is a wild strip of
coast the people captured beauty in
their spirits and never seemed to lack
anything as a result
so the world and all the pressures these
connections entail we have decided to
unplug completely and have come here
with no plans where are we going anyways
does it even matter if you start it is
this stuff is not it is like a kiss kiss
flutter scrap dick is granted his this
structure sky
Kiki's got against his captors guy Kiki
slapped adjusted structures gun Kiki's
got to just get stuck his gun
Kiki strategist this structures done you
just got to just get stuck
um the color white it's just like the
sound of silence when you can see
compassion in someone's eyes
looking out the window and seeing the
flicker of light through trees living
yeah by light living
I'm still trying to figure out who I am
how to live I'm in my head a lot I fight
it off with double espressos in the
mornings pressure on my face I want to
learn to dance I've been many places but
still searching for something more to
push through my anxieties to accomplish
something beautiful
I rise above the surface of moving water
drops trickling like a curtain covering
my vision as I take a lifetime to
descend
as my eyes left my heart sinks to the
depths of the ocean that has a working
beneath via creeps in and slowly burns
away my courage time stops and I try to
navigate this ocean my love towards it
has guided me here it is an instinct we
challenge much like stepping off the
edge of a cliff we attempt to overcome
the root of rationality we know exactly
what we do
driving to these locations just to
ultimately realize with every decision I
have the power to cut the ties of fear
stronghold and
fear is a funny thing
traveling with no direction no cell
phone I feel like you could take over
anytime but it forces us to observe the
landscape with a different eye when
we're in trouble
the locals always give a helping him
maybe that's the true essence of
traveling being dependent on the people
you mean opening yourself learning about
that culture what makes them unique what
makes us all the same
you know where he can
it's on
my friend
please hold
well
no change
honestly all no I
and I am feeling down
it's not your fault awaited
I'll kill you
this
we've gone in full circle to find
ourselves where we started but this time
around we felt closer to what we are and
we have memories - Amanda sits out there
our dreams waiting for us to get out of
our shells long live the young at heart
you know who you are with your spirit
burning take a risk take a chance
Terry on long live the soul set free
don't be afraid to dream while the world
is still turning every moment make it
happen with two left feet keep on
dancing beat by beat breast by brisk
walking hand step by step
Oh
Oh